dude this is a great idea this is why we
started this podcast for somebody to
come on and say yeah I just built a$1
million dollar Media company but guys
smoking Meats is where it's
[Music]
at what's up we got the Three Amigos of
newsletters the short story of Austin is
out of college create morning Brew sold
it for I think read 75 million so don't
you don't have to correct me if I'm
wrong but 75 million bucks you still run
it hundreds of employees amazing you
have a dock here of a bunch of topics
yeah someone sent me this deck like last
week and I I was like gonna text Sam
about this I was like you know what let
me wait for the Pod to talk to you guys
about this this is a I feel like a my
first million special so I've been super
excited about a bunch of these postco
get out of your house do exciting things
that's not go to a bar and just drink I
think that's pretty boring and there are
a bunch of these in New York I don't
know how if they have where you guys
live but but they have uh pingpong bars
and pull bars and they get more and more
uh out there and I was tweeting about
this and some guy sent me a deck he goes
I got something interesting for you so
if if you have your computer look up uh
bingo Loco right this guy sends me this
this deck for Bingo I'm like what the
hell is this right Bingo loo uh it's
basically a club meets Bingo right so
boozy Bingo performers Fetti showers the
the whole thing this looks like a Testo
concert or something going on what is
this I didn't know people played Bingo
off of cruise ships like I thought Bingo
was either for old people or cruise
ships he sends me his deck I don't want
to disclose their numbers but he goes
Check out one of our competitors uh
Bongo Bingo USA I'm like there's no like
there's no way there's a whole industry
for for Bingo Raves for Bingo parties
dude the websites are exactly the same
did they they just copied each other it
looks like they're I again he just sent
me a deck apparently people in the
industry so these Bongo Bingo guys
apparently preo were doing 20 million a
year in Revenue no
way explain this model do they own the
place or they're just going in like do
it a popup Bingo night at some place no
I think they go all it's actually really
smart right because what they do is I
believe they go for pretty off nights
for certain places right so you know so
kns were a club or whatever wherever
they had these wouldn't be that popular
but they still bring that environment
right they still use a lot of the
infrastructure that these these venues
have and they bring it seems like the
whole show the confetti showers the
performers everything and what I think
is interesting is they keep you there
with the Bingo right so there's a
there's a shuffle boarding place in
Brooklyn right they keep you there
because you play shuffle board for you
know hours and hours and you're just
buying drinks and that that's like the
the stick that's the hook to get you in
and this the same thing game of Bingo
I'm sure they have performers mid game
they keep you there for seven hours you
just buy a bunch of drink so I I thought
this one was awesome tickets are
$53 right now wow and they sell these
out I I guess they must be making money
off the boots right I was I was trying
to do more research there's not that
much information I never heard of it but
they must be making their money off of
the Boost well look at this ad so I went
to their ad
Library people of
Minneapolis a bingo Rave is coming to
Granada Theater March 15th which uh is a
couple months out it says after a sing
of sold out shows Across America big old
Loco it has Minneapolis and its sites
and then it's got like this Tik Tok
video which literally looks like you're
at like a rave and you go there and then
that's the know $30 ticket and then
there's like a you know what what is
this basically there's a host there's
music there's confetti there's um you
know dance offs link lip sync battles
there's a you know there's drinks
basically there's alcohol this is like
uh the
sound it's like that on a website that's
the business plan you open up a open up
a deck and it just plays that sound I've
got four words for you
[Laughter]
investors I'm sure the margins on this
are crazy their costs are some some
random performers in in in Bingo again I
I I I played Bingo one time on a cruise
ship and these guys are making what
seems like 20 million bucks a year off
off bingo I gota we got to figure out
what we can do this next for all right
everyone a quick break to tell you about
HubSpot and this one's really easy for
me to talk about because I'm going to
show you a real life example so I've got
this company called Hampton join
hampton.com it's a community for
Founders doing between 2 million all the
way up to like $250 million a year in
revenue and one of the ways that we've
grown is we've created these cool
surveys and so we have a lot of Founders
who have high net worth and we'll ask
them all types of questions that people
typically are embarrassed to ask but
provide a lot of value so things like
how much the founders pay themselves
each month how much money they're
spending each month what their payroll
looks like if they're optimistic about
the next year and their business all
these questions that people are afraid
to ask but well we ask them anyway and
they tell us in this Anonymous survey
and so what we do is we created a
landing page using hubspot's landing
page tool and it basically has a landing
page that says here's all the questions
we asked give us your email if you want
to access it and then I shared this page
on Twitter and we were able to get
thousands of people who gave us their
email and told us they want this survey
and I could see did they come from
social media I can see did they come
from Twitter from LinkedIn basically
everywhere else that they could possibly
come from I'm able to track all of that
and then I'm able to see over the next
handful of weeks how many of those
people actually signed up and became a
member of Hampton in other words I can
see how much revenue came from this
survey how much revenue came from each
traffic Source things like that but the
best part is I can see how much revenue
came from it and a lot of times it takes
a ton of work to make that happen
HubSpot made that super super easy if
you're interested in doing this you can
check it out hubspot.com the Link's in
the description and I also put the link
to the survey that I did so you can
actually see the landing page and how it
worked and everything like that I'm just
going to do that call to action
then and it's free check it out the
description all right now back to MFM so
you make a lot of money at morning Brew
doing digital stuff and you just hit
send on a little email that's easy kind
of kind of easy uh why on Earth do you
care about physical stuff that seems way
more challenging yeah I don't know if I
would ever start something in this space
but it's just so fun to go see to go see
the way people you know I would never
think this would work in a million years
I would never think Bingo uh uh own
steroids Bingo uh performers would work
but I think it's so interesting I love
going to these things around the city to
try to see how people get people hooked
on these things it's so easy to hook
people in a newsletter right it's it's
content every day it's very different
people come back to to play shuffle
board or bingo so I I love these I have
an idea for one can I pitch you guys one
all right so I'm try you know as soon as
you set this Bingo thing my brain starts
the wheels start
turning and Sam you'll appreciate this
you like the UFC so I don't know if you
remember when Conor McGregor was on his
come up uh he was knocking people out he
was knocking people out it was the best
and this guy everyone's like what can't
this guy do because everybody thought
whoever the next guy he's fighting that
guy's gonna neutralize him with this
this and this knocks him out and I
remember watching uh one you know ex USC
fighter he was doing like an analysis
and he's like I'm watching Connor he
does all this spinning [__] he does this
he does this he's like I think it's all
smoking mirrors he goes I think
everything is just a distraction because
he's trying to land the left hand and
he's like you know that's every all this
stuff he's throwing he doesn't care what
happen happens with it he's just trying
to hit you with the left hand to me this
is the same business model like the
Bingo it's it's like oh you hear about
that Bingo business no no no you he
about that alcohol business that uses
Bingo to get you to the bar so similarly
we got to figure out what's going to get
people to the bar and get them drinking
and so here's my idea I've always wanted
to enter one of those eating contests I
don't know if you guys have ever done
one I've never actually done it but like
those places where it's like if you can
eat this pizza it's free and like I've
always wanted to actually go do it but
there's always like this problem where
it's like it's like you have to pay $75
to like buy the huge Pizza it might be
free but you you know whatever I would
love if somebody turn this into like you
know if I was in college I would have
been all over this if it was like it's
it's the contest is who can eat the
biggest you know who can eat the most
hot dogs or the biggest pizza who could
finish it the fastest and you can go
enter and you have to bring friends to
be kind of your cheering section they're
all Rowdy and drinking and cheering you
on it's free to play because the pizza's
not that expensive but you're going to
fill up the bar with like you know
whatever hundreds of people who are in
the mood to kind of like binge and go
extreme because that's kind of the theme
of the night in a way it's like sports
Meats binge eating well what's the best
thing that goes with both those things
binge drinking who's with me the only
thing you can add is a little bit of
gambling you need to have people gamble
this is this is like gamble it's like
gambling right it's it's it's it's Vegas
meets a party
so beautiful yes and there Austin I
don't know if you've been doing some
improv but that was a beautiful yes S I
really appreciate that one good riff I
follow this guy on YouTube he's called
beer meets food and looks like he has uh
3.6 million subscribers have you guys
seen this guy he just goes to small
restaurants in England that they have
like you know uh you get this free if
you eat it he eats roughly 10,000
calories in each of the challenges and
he Nails all of them like one time he
ate like I think it was five pounds of
chocolate have you seen this Sean this
guy's channel it's the craziest Channel
I've ever seen and I watch all videos
it's one of the few YouTube channels I
subscribe to this guy needs to La launch
your food challenge gambling business
and there's actually a bunch of these
instagramers that you could do this with
so uh you know there's that guy who eats
the raw meat I think he's called raw
meat experiment read his bio read his
bio Sean his bio
great so 142,000 followers he goes
eating raw meat every day until I die
from
bacteria then it says line two seeing if
I live for five days or 500
years and literally he'll just a chunk
of ground beef and he just sits outside
of a Whole Foods he buys the ground beef
and he just eats it raw or he'll just
get a chicken breast uncooked and he'll
just chew it like it's a you know I
don't know like a slim gym or something
like that and uh I feel like these
there's so many Instagram food mukbang
like different variations of this like
there's a lot of YouTubers that that do
this where they order just an insane
amount of food watch me eat and it is
entertaining to do I could feel like you
could get them to
be like kind of guest host promotional
to to do these popups I used to um when
I worked uh when I moved to San
Francisco I didn't have a lot and I
would part-time I had like a part-time
job and I worked for this guy Joe Garvey
he had a company called Clash it stood
for California League of Adventure
scavenger hunt or something like that it
was called Clash SF and he was making
seven figures a year and we would host
these
Citywide uh scavenger hunts and they
were the best it was so fun and I got to
see some of the like economics of like
some of these in-person stuff and I was
actually pretty shocked at how great
some of these could be it was a lot of
work um and then we have another friend
Nick Gray did you know Sean that Nick
Gray had a business called Museum hack
and he eventually sold it and it was
doing many many millions in revenue and
the way the business worked where was he
eventually or at first it was just like
gorilla where he was he would like go to
I think it was met the the Met uh in um
New York it's a free museum and people
would pay $50 and he would give them
tour of the museum and he would explain
the the art and then eventually he hired
lots of theater kids to lead these tours
and he had them set up in a variety of
museums throughout the country and
eventually he had a partnership after
they like kicked him out a bunch of
times and uh he said that business was
awesome dude I I love the way he
described it too he uses the phrase
Renegade Museum tours I just thought
that was just a great way to pitch it
he's like yeah I my first business I
hosted Renegade Museum tours and he
doesn't really explain what it is but
you try to put it all together and the
word Renegade I feel like is is uh
underutilized underhyped word I think
I'm going to try to try to bring that
back into my my everyday uh vocabulary I
think they made him I think time out
made him the number one uh thing to do
in New York and I think that's what blew
him up right he blew up and then and
then of course he went B to B because
that's where the money and all this
stuff is Right selling in you sell a
consumer for 50 bucks you sell a morning
Brew for 20 grand and our HR team just
sides off and approves
it Austin last time you were here I
think we we talked about like the
Creator economy and I'm almost certain
all three of us were like this is going
to fizzle out and has your opinion
changed and I know like some things have
happened in like the news or the media
world that has uh got you excited tell
me about that yeah I think uh last time
we spoke I remember we were all talking
and we're like what's the next milk Road
for right milk Road for X we were all
talking about that uh and we're like oh
AI is popping off let's let's so want
you launch the milk Road for AI milk
Road for X that just got Sha all all
he's all hot man you're you're you're
speaking to him perfectly Austin got on
the call called me skinny and now he
said milk Road for hex X instead of
morning Brewer hustle for x and I am
this guy's a charmer I love it just
trying to Hype you up Sean uh I mean
look but there was 10,000 I mean there's
beehives growing off the backs of of
milk Road for AI and I think the the
problem with these business are they
their content is not very good they've
all grown with these these crazy growth
hacks which is great for the you know
newsletter ecosystem as a whole
but it's not sustainable I think there's
there's nowhere Alpha in the the
newsletter game everyone talks about
everything and I think beehive did for
newsletters what Shopify did for
e-commerce right e-commerce stores
started and people got super pumped
they're like you know investors invested
it away and then all these businesses
because they're like oh Shopify makes it
so easy to start an e-com store and
that's awesome the problem was they made
it too easy to start an e-com store
where everyone started e-com store where
you have to be either the absolute best
or you just can't raise a bunch of money
have to be okay with it being like a
fine business but everyone's just
pouring in again not a ton of money but
a ton of people just think oh if I can
just create the the milk Road for
marketing the milk Road for uh AI I'm
gonna have a a milk Road like exit I
just I don't know what you guys think
but I just don't think these newsletters
have a ton of value let me ask you a
different question uh you spent a bunch
of time in media now how long you been
doing this like s eight years something
like that coming up on 10 oh my God uh
wow incred a third of your life you've
spent in the media business I hope you
don't spend the next two-thirds of your
life on the media business too if you
were gonna do something different where
would you go let's say media was off the
table um what would you do next yeah so
I think there are two types of
businesses I love I think one is uh you
know B2B I think you know we've all
built businesses where the ltvs are like
15 bucks that's pretty tough uh I love
you know selling significant Enterprise
Products the other one is building into
passion audiences that's I think where
I'd actually go so you know we went to
Camp my first Million last year and we
met that guy I think his name is Al
who's building for Quilters Al Don yeah
um I think he does hundreds of millions
of Revenue so I think I want want to
find a niche there figure out you what
is a weird Niche so the one I've been
spending a lot of time researching I
almost did something here I ended up not
doing it is meat smoking
I am obsessed with my Trager right d how
do you use a Trager you live in an
apartment in New York like on your
balcony yeah on the I live on the first
floor so I I have access to the common
space so I don't I don't meat smoke what
what even is meat smoking can you just
give me that but first dud it's such a
pain in the ass it is such a pain in the
ass called grilling or it's different
than grilling you cook you cook meat at
like 200 degrees for like 10 12 hours
it's like barbecuing but 10 hours and no
fire and they use smoke instead I all my
my Jewish friends are into this because
you guys grew up eating brisket you got
to wait 10 hours to eat and you've got
to buy like special like wood chips for
it it's a [__] pain in the ass I've
Got Friends that will wake up at 4 in
the morning to like get their brisket
started okay but I'm a Believer anything
that's a huge pain in the ass that
people do there's like a [__] ton of
money there exactly right and so there's
a couple big brands in smoking there's
trigger right trigger is the one I have
and the thing is to Sam's Point you
don't just like it's not electricity you
just like turn it on and it goes you
have to uh it's it's wood pellets right
you literally smoke wood pellets and
these pellets Trager gets you to buy the
,500 smoker but then also you're
spending $50 every time you smoke Meats
because you're just furing these pellets
and there's a lot of meat smokers uh
influencers out there these guys in
Nashville guys in Texas and literally
it's like how to smoke a ribey how to
smoke a brisket and they have tens of
millions of views and they're all like
kind of sophisticated they have these
rug that you put in your Meats but none
of them are taking big swings right none
of them are build are building the
Trager competitor I want to build the
Trager or the green EG competitor sell
the $1,500 product sell the $50 a month
$100 a month pellet and build the next
Trager which I think is a multi billion
dollar brand dude I'm I'm fired up I'm
smoked up right now that was a good
pitch and you you seem pretty lit up
about that uh why did you not do this
this sounds awesome I've been talking to
some some meat smoking
influencers uh I'm working on it the the
the meat smoking boys that's what we'll
call them what I like about these guys
are they're just so much more downto
Earth than these New York City
influencers you know it's not like that
the the Tik Tock 22-year-olds these are
people who just love life they just want
to smoke meats and if they can sell a
grill even better there's there's this
guy have you heard this guy um Jonathan
Moses Catz no who's that so he's a he's
a woodworking Creator right and he's
done kind of what I'm saying but in The
Woodworking Niche so what this guy has
done he was a big woodworking Creator
and he built some tools for and it's
cool because obviously he's a woodworker
so he can build them himself for his a
dude his site his ssite gets so much
traffic this guy kills it I bet crushes
it right and so I spoke to this guy one
time so I don't I don't have you know
any Insider information but he crushed
it and what he started to do is he
started to partner with every other
woodworking Creator and said hey look
I'm doing you know crushing it for
myself selling a bunch of whatever
widgets to my audience let me make you
your own custom little thing your in
your woodworking Niche and I'm going to
help you all sell them as well and then
we can build a collective store of all
our all our products and and Sean if you
sell one on behalf of Sam you'll kick
him an affiliate this is a big business
I bet you he does 50 million a year on
so it's called km tools I think right k
yeah km tools I bet you this does in the
50 million range yeah I I wouldn't be
surprised if it does more dude this is a
great idea this is why we started this
podcast for somebody to come on and say
yeah I just built a100 million Media
company but guys smoking Meats is where
it's at this is a niche You' never
really thinking about there's an
opportunity here here's the here's the
distribution model we're going to use
I'm going to partner with these
influencers and then do this kind of
affiliate Network and build this
competitor this is awesome we're going
to call it the meat smoking Jerky Boys
and we're going to this this what this
this way it allows us a little bit of a
lateral expansion into the beef jerky
space but we're gonna call it the meat
smoking Jerky Boys no dude you know that
you know that um that cigarette brand
that we we love The Branding of the
packaging of Oklahoma smokes yeah I feel
like you kind of gotta do a Oklahoma
smokes or like a a Nashville Nashville
smokes club uh or something like that
brought to you by The Jerky Boys and uh
you know I think it's all needs to come
together into one Mega
brand I have not seen this branding this
is awesome Oklahoma smokes we're
stealing this we're buying the company
just to steal The Branding dude they're
so good Google like some of the most
popular towns in Louisiana and just pick
one name that like stands out you know
like tupo meats or
something I'm just I'm just hoping a big
meat smoking influencer Creator listens
to this podcast and DMS me on Twitter
and goes I'm ready to ride the back
Rouge smoke company God there's just so
many possibilities here um Austin I know
when we started this conversation I
didn't even know what smoking beats was
but I'm in and hold a little check space
for me on this company because I love to
be a part of this you know I'm the
opposite of an expert adviser here I'm
actually GNA be your your in-house
beginner and that's how I'm gonna add
some value to you dude even Zuck into it
remember remember the whole the the Zuck
uh meme about uh smoking meats or
whatever yeah he loves smoking Meats
[Laughter]
and you're you're into this I know that
for a minute Austin you were talking
about how you're like I want to partner
with creators because I because like
once you can attach with some of these
folks you just you kill it is that what
you would do I mean for this yeah I
think that is still uh it ever it's very
popular these days to partner with
creators I still think that's the future
I still think we're we're scratching the
surface you know there's beables and
Prime and and everyone talks about those
and it's definitely been played out in
terms of talking about but I still think
ultimately you're going to walk into a
liquor store you're going to walk into
Target and every brand is going to have
a face and Association because why
wouldn't it right if there's a brand
that could have nobody attached to it or
a brand that could have someone attached
to it why wouldn't that brand have the
built-in distribution of you guys or
someone you know more more widely
wellknown or or just someone like I just
don't see how that doesn't play out and
so you know it's it's been done with the
the biggest creators I think the real
opportunities in the niches Sean how big
do you think first of all we don't
really have that many like cool
interests that you could have like an
MFM product in Target like what what are
we gonna [__] sell red Solo cups like
I don't even know like what what what is
there like Tupperware like uh I I don't
know like what we could possibly sell be
the dumbest thing that would be
associated
with like a notebook I don't I have no
idea but MFM slinkies baby let's go how
popular like what's like so bar stool
has like the bar stool razor they're in
uh uh stores so and they're a way bigger
brand than they have frozen pizza they
have like other things they have a bunch
of stuff how famous do we have to be do
you think in order to make a dent into
like getting sales at Target so I don't
think that famous if you pick the right
product I actually think we're past the
point or do you become more famous do
you get more famous because your shit's
in Target like oh my God they're
actually in Target I think we're past
the point where just spame is going to
drive right I think that works for for a
few people but I think you actually need
to have a great product I think you had
them on the Pod you know Danny Austin
and uh her husband Jordan yeah Danny's
Big but Danny's not as big as some of
these other creators but her brand is
worth way more than almost every brand
out there because it's actually a
product that has a need it's not hey
we're gonna rip off you know one of the
biggest brands on the planet it there's
a true it's a great product Oh Sam we
could have done
hymns or like the trt subscriptions or
something like
should have said hibs that would have
been our
move have you ever taken it no is it
good I've never taken it either I I've
never tried it Austin have you you're
younger than we are have you done it no
I have not all right guys we know what
we're doing next time we hang out
yeah doing a podcast we're gonna be
playing
swords so I think that this is gonna be
like the new newsletter thing I think
that people looked at febles they looked
at Prime and they looked at skims and
they're like Creator brand and every
Creator is like I need to do a Creator
brand and every like former drop shipper
is like I just need a Creator and then
we win and they're all going to go do
this and then they're all gonna wash out
there's obviously going to be a few
winners because the difference right
like what Logan Paul did with prime is
so different than what most creators do
with their product like that guy a had
like actually like a humongous audience
took it everywhere built the brand sort
of like Brick by Brick oh he's at
WrestleMania guess what he's going to
[__] the guy over the head with a
giant bottle of prime or like you know
there's one and it was him and KSI right
so they got two huge creators two big
markets to pair together to go into this
industry you know Mr Beast is like I'm
gonna do Feasta but he's not just like
hey go guys go buy my chocolate he's
like I rebuilt Willy Wonka's chocolate
factory for three million dollars and
that's how I'm going to launch this
thing I'm gonna make the product the
content the content is the product
there's no line between the two and you
know so you know he those worked because
the creators really were like actual
Entre and partnered with world class
operators to pull them off right like we
talked about the guys behind prime those
guys are monsters right those guys are
in their 20s and mega billionaires for a
reason have built multiple beverage
brands for a reason the guy who built
Conor McGregor's whiskey brand was also
the guy who did like whatever two other
alcohol brands that were multi-billion
dollar dollar Brands and they they
partnered with him to do proper 12 so
and same thing Connor is like mega mega
famous and went all the way with the
promotion versus other people may not I
think the Danny Austin story is good
because it was like her real story was
like postpartum I was losing hair I was
ashamed of it I bought wigs for the last
year I've been wearing wigs while I've
been an influencer but instead I really
wanted to find a product that would work
and here's the product here's my before
and after and it's like that's like the
perfect combination of things you have
high margin product you have repeat
purchase because people are gonna have
they have to keep applying the thing you
have a visual before and after and you
have a true story around the creators
like actual need versus just like a nice
to have and you know that is like the
you know that's the the yatsi of putting
these these together most people are not
gonna be able to do that yeah but Austin
you could do it you you youve got that
operator Gene you could be one of these
nerds well the thing is we're we're all
doing it in the B2B space right so what
we're doing is not is like okay we have
one 100th the audience of a Mr Beast or
a Logan Paul cool so we need to sell a
product that's 100 times more expensive
than a bottle of prime right he he sells
his for four bucks or whatever we're
trying to sell products that cost 4,000
or $40,000 or $400,000 a year by doing
B2B software right that's why HubSpot
did it with us and I think this is the
other thing like Austin you did a thread
that was like this is the new thing but
it's like dude people have been doing
celebrity endorsements forever the
difference is that now the celebrities
own Equity I'm like oh yeah people can
do this wait a minute we did it that's
us yeah exactly that's good for their
brand right like to to help them sell a
product that's worth thousands of
dollars right it would be smart of us to
do that not the uh the MFM whatever like
Target brand nail clippers yeah leg
exactly adult Legos yeah and Sam I think
really that that is you and Hampton like
you really are I mean it's it's a what
$8,000 product like I think that is the
perfect example you may not be Tony
Robbins right you may not be Gary ve or
maybe they're the equivalent of like the
Logan Paul and B2B but you found a great
product and then makes a lot of sense
for your brand and your audience and so
I yeah I think it's a it's a home run
yeah keep Shilling speaking of Tony
Robins Austin you know this episode's
gonna come out right after the episode
with Tony Robbins so uh yeah which is
good for Austin I think that's good for
Austin no I mean maybe but I I meant to
start with this actually so maybe we'll
cut this and put it at the beginning but
you know when when you start a not to
shill Hampton again I hate to do this
but when you start a a Hampton session
with your your group you you air
grievances right everyone say c can you
be honest with everyone can you really
have a good dialogue and discussion or
is there anything you need to get out in
the open well clearly we could because I
didn't say this but but I I do need to
tell everyone that Monday you and I were
supposed to talk like one o'clock Sean's
like I'm gonna I'm gonna call you Austin
I give you a call one o'clock comes by
no call two o'clock comes by no call so
I text you I'm like Sean what's going on
you're like oh I'm prepping for the big
you're texted me thanks for the
call
better and so I'm like Sean what the
heck's going on you're like I'm I'm I'm
prepping for the big guest I'm like oh
Sean's hyping me up like 10 minutes
later by the way that was actually Tony
Robbins not
you yeah so basically like he reached
out or someone on his team reached out I
had a thing planned and also Sean is
like the biggest fan so Sean it was
awesome that you got to like just hang
out with a guy you admired how was it it
was intense is the way I would explain
it I mean when I tell you I prepared for
for this not only did I basically spend
every waking moment for two days just
like PR preparing for this thing which I
never do for podcast um I've also kind
of been preparing for 10 years because I
follow the guy and I'm a big fan of what
he's I've been to three of his seminars
like right I know a lot and there's
there's kind of a curse of knowing too
much going in and so like meeting your
Heroes type of thing yeah it's like you
want it to go well so bad it's almost
like you squeeze the like don't don't
squeeze the bar of soap too hard it just
squirts out like if you if you want it
to go so well it's going to [__] out
I'll tell you guys the the funny part so
like interesting analogy interesting
analogy it's not the bar of soap analogy
you thought I was going to
do I took The Road Less Traveled there
so so we're getting ready for the podt
it's me and Ari were sitting there and
his team's like you know team is like
swarming the computer setup they're like
Tony will be here shortly uh you know
just everything's okay and I'm like all
right sweet I never get here early you
know I'm like chronically late but for
this one 20 minutes early so I'm sitting
there for like 10 minutes and I could
just feel myself getting cold I'm like
like oh no I can't just sit here and I
was like I got to use the [__] Tony
teaches you you got to be in state you
want to have a Peak Performance you got
to be in a peak state of course right
athletes do that well guess what what's
one step down from an athlete a musician
what's 25 steps down from that a
podcaster and so I got up and I start
doing my like Tony Robbins power move
where I'm like I'm basically doing this
like really dorky like midback stretch
to like you know unlock my [__]
chakras or something like that try to
get some energy flowing and then I just
hear Hello and it's Tony Robbins I'm
like rush back to my desk like oh
hey yeah sorry you're just staring at my
chair there as I was doing like you know
Tony Robin stretches in the corner
Trying To Get Hype for this he just
hears like offscreen Sean saying like
I'm the man who's the man I'm the man
I'm the man even better I'm visualizing
thanks Tony I had a good time
too you want my number let me get it for
you I'm I'm working backwards from the
desired end State just like you just me
but he hears it off off off camera and
and it went well it I mean I'm not gonna
give away too much but let me just say
this tears were shed and they weren't
mine and if there's one mark of a
successful Tony like life accomplishment
I wouldn't say he cried wouldn't say
what but he you know teared up and so
you know I thought that that was a you
know a good thing but it's really hard
to interview somebody who is a stage
performer like Sam you must feel like
this sometimes when I'm just monologuing
monologuing monologuing like right now
he's on he's like a next level at that
and it's all good stuff but it's like
you know it's like you poke the thing
and an avalanche comes out were you ever
like uh all right Tony shut the [__] up
let me ask my next question so
uh just got like only 45 minutes they
were like um like you got 45 minutes
with Tony and I was like 45 minutes geez
this guy does n9h hour a day seminars
for four days straight like what am I
going to do in 45 minutes and
then and I'm like hey uh you know
actually it might be better if we do
this in person I'm I will fly to you
tomorrow and I'll be there and his team
was like um no thanks uh we'll do you
stay over there we'll do it this way
instead but it was it was good I enjoyed
it uh I do think I'm gonna just make a
prediction Austin sorry to to Big Dog
you with the Tony Robins thing but I'll
give you this compliment I think people
are going to like this episode more
because the Rapport and also just like
the style of stuff we talk about is so
like you know on point for for what this
podcast is can I ask you a different
story though about a big name yeah go
ahead a couple years ago you texted us
that you were going to dinner with SBF
and at the time SBF was the next Mark
Zuckerberg SBF was multi-billionaire of
the fastest growing private startup um
boy Genius from MIT who wor like cargo
Jorts and uh we were like Dude tell us
more and you were like can't got to put
way my phone right now like you know you
know see you later suckers I'm going to
go have dinner with SP SPF can you now
two years later can you tell us the
story what was it like going to dinner
with SF yeah he's not gonna do anything
now right he's in jail for a long time I
think so maybe one day I'll get out and
I'll listen to this episode I don't
think I've told this story publicly uh
so I'll tell it um but I have a friend
investor at a big VC invested in FTX and
you this is probably I don't know 2021
so SBF was BF right this is pre him
obviously getting caught as being a
fraud but he's at the height of his
power he was whatever the stat was that
top richest you know the richest person
under 35 in the world the oneliner for
anyone who doesn't know who SPF is Sam
bakman freed he was like the Bernie made
off of crypto 31y old worth2 billion do
and it all came crashing down now he's
in prison for fraud okay go ahead great
thanks for the background um it's gonna
make me look really good um so I uh
didn't know that much about him though
like I didn't do any research uh I'd
heard him talk a couple times but I
didn't know any of the stories and so my
friend's like we trips to Bahamas I'm
like I'm in it's for his birthday so we
show up and I've been to nice places
right I stayed at the Ritz Carlton I
stayed all these nice places and so I
thought I knew where the Rich and Famous
live I was wrong this place it's called
the Albany and the Bahamas this is where
the Rich and Famous live like this place
was there were 250 foot yachts
everywhere I mean this is I I think
Tiger Woods owns it uh Justin Bieber who
I actually met the next day lives there
Will Smith lives there like this is
where the Rich and Famous live it was
nuts and so I get there I'm like oh [__]
like yeah we're in for it so we show up
we actually stayed at someone else at
ftxs house they put you in the guest
boat which was a pretty pretty nice
guest house though no it was not a boat
but it was a house and so we show up and
we get get there here's the first thing
I observe right it's like the penthouse
coer $25 million apartment I had no idea
I was walking into I walk in and there
are 50 pairs of shoes laying everywhere
like crappy Nikes I'm like this dude's
worth 30 billion and they're all these
weird Nikes laying around and my
friend's like oh yeah I forgot to tell
you like the entire exec team lives
together in this one
apartment and I'm like oh boy what are
you what is going on and so obviously
now we know in hindsight like you know
there were articles who knows if it's
true they were having orgies and all all
type of of weird [__] so we I knew all
this like I knew some weird stuff was
going on because 50 people did you get
the orgy Vibe did you get like did could
you smell it yeah smell but there was a
weird Alpha attitude that people had
towards Sam like he was clearly the
alpha in the room even though he's super
nerdy super techy but he just had this
weird thing where people anyone who said
anything looked to Sam to make sure they
approved like it was clear he he was in
charge he was the man and so again first
thing shoes second thing you look to the
left and Sam is in the kitchen cooking
food which I was like oh we probably the
chef cook us dinner no Sam is there
cooking us food he does not turn his
back his his face to us his back is to
us and he starts having a full
conversation with us without ever making
eye
contact no I contact he goes the first
thing he ever says to me and my friend
is so what do you think about Indian
crypto changes what and I'm like what is
going on Indian because he hasn't turned
around yet he doesn't realize you're
white
guy I don't know so so in my friend know
did you have an answer to that I
probably said four words the entire
dinner they were speaking a different a
different language you know all all all
crypto stuff um so I show up in the
kitchen and Sam's cooking us dinner I
put dinner in quotes everyone got one
Beyond sausage and two Russell Sprouts
that was the meal for for everyone so I
think the vegan stuff's true because he
cooked us all Beyond sausage right so
that was pretty weird we sit down so
again $20 million apartment but there's
Hardware everywhere cables everywhere it
was like post-apocalyptic right it was
super super weird being this $20 million
apartment but there's like PS3s and
Xboxes like everywhere a complete mess
of an apartment and so we sit down and I
think the craziest thing about the
dinner was Sam was a genius when it came
to the things he had to know for FTX and
crypto so for example Tom Brady was a
like sponsored by FTX right Sam could
have told you every single thing about
Tom Brady could have told you his
statline everything about him but I
don't think Sam knew what a first down
was I don't think he knew a single thing
about football but if it benefited
crypto he was the smartest person on the
planet same thing with politicians he
could go every single Senator every
Supreme Court Justice he could tell you
their exact stance on crypto I don't
think he could tell you a single other
thing about them it was
incredible dude Sean you and I I don't
want to I don't want to say their name
because I don't want this be an insult
but you and I hung out with someone who
was the best in the whole world at what
they do and well [__] it I'll say it it
was Mr Beast he was the best at whatever
this is not an insult I guess it was Mr
Beast you know he's the best in the
world and I remember I think it was
either you or me or me and someone else
and I we were just shooting the [__]
about like a TV show that I thought
everyone knew about and he had he had no
idea and I was like I was just like
curious about this so I asked some more
pop culture stuff didn't know anything
about like this normal stuff he's like
sorry I just pay attention to YouTube
like I that's all I do he had the exact
same thing where he didn't know anything
about anything outside of his expertise
there's a funny uh interview with Conor
McGregor on BBC it's like uh you know
usually UFC gets covered by these small
n Outlets but one time like he got on
the main BBC they were like they were
shooting the [__] before the interview
they were like oh how about the game you
know whoever like some soccer game like
some famous soccer game he's like he
just laughs he's like he's like haha
yeah it was great go he goes yeah it was
great and they go you don't watch soccer
do you he goes no I have no idea what
you're talking about and go he goes do
he goes um I don't know what's happening
in the news I don't know what's
happening in the world uh he goes I have
lost my mind to the game and I only know
about my [__] don't give a damn about
anything else and I think that's like
actually kind of common for people who
get like top 0.011% of like what they're
trying to trying to become it's like
when they asked Trump what his favorite
like verse in the Bible was and he goes
you know what I love all of them I love
all of them yeah too hard to pick I love
them
all that's what Conor McGregor was like
I love all the
sports you seen the the video of of
LeBron he's on Instagram live and people
are like oh who are your favorite soccer
players and LeBron's like he's like I
love soccer they asked him about the
team he owns they were like who are your
favorite PSG players or whatever and
he's like he owns the team and he's like
he names one and he's like you know such
as such as I mean you know so and so
forth there are so many it's like etc
etc such as yeah you only use the the
middle words of a sentence you didn't
say the
subject did you get fraud Vibes when you
were there or were you also tricked I
mean I was totally enamored I because
the perception at the ALB like there was
a buzz we took a cab to the ALB and
the's like oh you're going to uh you
know like the AL that's where that's
where FTX is headquarter like oh yeah
we're like we're GNA see Sam and
everyone's like oh my God everyone's
like yo we one of the security guards
said You know here you know you think
the celebrities are famous the famous
people they want to meet Sam Sam doesn't
want to meet the people they want to go
meet Sam like this guy he just had this
Aura around him everyone wanted to meet
him now in hindsight I feel like a
complete [__] because there were so
many red flags every the whole effective
altruism thing he he par you guys know
about that yeah make as much money as
you can to give it away yes what I heard
about this never mind's like yeah you
know Sam lives a really low-key
lifestyle I'm like guys he lives in a 25
or2 million
apartment it's the nicest apartment I've
ever been in and they're all like no he
only lives there because it's the most
convenient to the FTF yeah yeah he lives
in an orgy compound and he's he lives a
lowkey
life we we just throve by the FTX office
there were 75 you neighborhoods in
between here and the office like that
doesn't add up what is going on yeah
because these videos came out that was
like Sam still drives his 93 Corolla and
he's just like shrugs like why do I need
to get a better car car and it's like oh
damn this guy's full of [__] you know
like wow he's got like a full Olympic
siiz swimming pool on his on his balcony
but he he's an EA he's not spending his
money there was a there was a rumor that
he was uh that they're high on some type
of like uh you know Aderall type of
medicine that was like a patch did you
see any of that [__] laying around no I
wish again like hindsight 2020 I wish I
was looking for this stuff because I was
just so enamored by this guy and how
well he knew crypto but I just wish I
started like digging and looking through
more stuff I'm sure there was crazy [__]
everywhere dude you also I don't know if
you probably can't say this but you went
and hung out with Kid Rock as well uh
which is like a crazy story you've hung
out with some cool people you've had
some diverse experiences yeah the Kid
Rock thing I think I might spoke about
that last time the Kid Rock thing was
awesome he is he's obviously super
interesting I he told us he is the only
person to play at both President Obama
and president Trump's inaugurations and
he knows both them he's the only one
that can heal this country he's the only
one that can bring us
together he he lives in this this he
actually on his compound which it is a
compound he has like a full bar uh and I
don't mean like the the physical bar I
mean like a whole pub at on his compound
he also lives and I it was being
constructed but he lives in a house that
is a replica of the White House I'll
show you guys pictures it he modeled it
after the White House walk up you're
like oh my God like it actually looks
exactly like the White House looked like
it's nuts all right everyone really
quick this is Sam I'm going to do a
thrill of the chill so basically I've
got an ask for everyone out there I just
launched this new podcast it's called
MoneyWise it's a personal finance
podcast for high netw worth people you
can find it by looking up MoneyWise on
Spotify and uh iTunes or wherever else
you get your podcast but here's the deal
this podcast is a ton of work and I'm
only hosting the first handful of
episodes I need someone to be the host
of this podcast I have a feeling it's
going to be pretty pretty big and it's
going to be great for whoever hosts it
but I need help hosting it I don't want
to do all the work our first episode you
can find it on whatever all those
platforms it's pretty great I think it's
with the guy who sold his company for
$200 million and we get to hear like how
he breaks down his net worth how much he
spends each month all this transparent
money stuff that's pretty interesting
and so if you want to host it I'm
actually not going to give out my
contact information you've got to figure
out how to contact me because that's
what you're gonna have to do you're
gonna have to find guests so contact me
and let me know if you want to be the
host of this and send me something that
is impressive that shows that you have
what it takes all right back to the show
awesome did you ever hear the story Cody
Co told on our pod about when he went to
Elon musk's house for a party
no it's so funny it's a very short story
but I find it hilarious even though it's
not meant to be a funny story he's just
telling what happened but the whole idea
is so funny to me so he goes he's like
yeah I was hanging out with so Cody's
like you know La YouTuber cool guy also
makes some music so I think they were
hanging out with um post Malone so he's
he's had a thing with post he's like oh
Elon asked us to you know come over for
a party he shows him his phone he's like
you want to go and he's like uh of
course okay let's go so they go to El's
house I was like what's it like he's
like first thing no furniture in the
entire place an empty house and he was
like uh does anybody live here like what
is this he's like no no elon's house is
across the street this is like his party
he hosts people here he lives over there
I like oh naturally okay a stupid
question by me dumb all right I won't
ask he's like so we're just sitting
there and he's like uh it's like a fire
and they're just kind of like eating you
know like uh eating marshmallows or
whatever the [__] and he's like he's
like you know it got kind of late people
are doing their own thing and he's like
you know all I'm just gonna go I'm just
gonna kind of dip out of here this is
like you know it's it's late this was
weird and he's like so he he's trying to
leave he doesn't know his way out of the
house so he's like trying to get out he
turns the corner and it's just Elon
making out with
Grimes so he just turns and he opens
this door and he's like he's he's like
dude I thought I was G to open this door
and there's just a rocket and they're
like get in there's no
time he like I just wanted to leave so
bad you guys read the the Elon book I
didn't read it I I'm kind of over Elon
Sean and I are both over him hardcore
but I don't want to read that book
because it sounds so
stressful yeah I I just finished it I
read it uh over the holidays and it
definitely gives you a different lens
into Elon Musk you really really see the
full spectrum of of who he is as a
person and I think people try to draw
inspiration from Elon and I think you
can in little bits and pieces but to me
my big takeaway from the whole book was
like Elon is Hardcore like that is the
one word he uses and like that is who he
is he's hardcore he's extreme I don't
think you can be like 70% Elon and be
successful like he just has no regard
for any person he works with he's
basically everyone he works with right
he he you know treats his family like
[__] he's starved from issues with his
dad and my big take away it was like
elon's this unique one you know one in a
billion one in 10 billion people and all
these people are inspired that's great
but don't try to copy him because this
guy is is to the extreme and I I don't
think almost anyone can can be as
extreme in every facet of life he
doesn't sleep he doesn't vacation he has
crazy relationships I mean obviously
that's all public but with all uh you
know he has so many kids but it's all
everything's extreme every single thing
he does is to the as Extreme as you can
possibly do it it's it's incredible you
you should read the book dude I just
don't want my blood pressure to rise
reading that like just hearing you talk
about this because on one hand I'm like
when I hear about him I'm like oh I'm
soft I should step it up and then on the
other hand I'm like his life sucks I do
not want that and so there is that whole
you can't be you can't be like him and
be SE and be 70% have I told you my
David goggin's point I think that's what
applies here which is what you only want
to be David Goggins for one hour a
day that's the whole trick with David
gogins you you can't be you don't want
to be out on all of David gogins because
he's inspiring and he's so tough and
he's so like mentally strong that
there's something to learn there you
also don't want to subscribe to the
David gogin lifestyle or even like try
to emulate you know half of what he's
doing you just want for one hour a day
when you're working out to just shift
into David goggin gear for that one hour
and then never never touch it again like
I don't know if you saw this post that
was uh David Goggins is engaged and his
Beyonce [__] insane it sounds like an
onion article I was just gonna say
there's this video of her I didn't even
know he's engaged I don't know how he's
in a relationship first of all but I
here's here's what I actually saw we're
g put this on the YouTube just like get
YouTube May delete our account are they
like we just got home from dinner or
something first there's a picture of his
toes which is just like I don't know if
you've ever seen it ex-athletes toes but
they're like all nasty as hell this guy
I don't even know what's going on he's
literally just ripping off his big
toenail because he's like ah don't need
this [__] anymore like and F's like no
David please don't and like whatever and
he's like why are his feet so jacked up
because he's running hundred miles at a
time and so she posts this thing she's
like yeah a lot of people think that
David only turns it on for the camera I
just want to show you this he just he's
two we two months out of uh no two weeks
off of surgery for his leg where they
like broke his leg and fixed it for
whatever reason and um he just came home
and was like I want to run 100 miles
tonight and so she's following him in
the car she's been with him in the car
for like eight hours she's falling
behind at like five miles an hour or
whatever and he's just running he's he's
on you know hour seven yeah hour seven
it's like you know 3:00 am and he's
almost done with 100 miles I think it
said like I think it said like we got
home from dinner and David just looks at
me and goes I've got to go run 100 miles
now or like I got to run a Tru what's
what are they called trucks or something
like that I got to go go do a truck
tonight uh I forgot what they're called
called but like a Ruck so I'm going for
a Ruck tonight and I don't I'm this out
of shape I don't even know what a Ruck
is let alone running with a it's running
or walking with a backpack on that has
weight in it okay so he's doing 100 mile
weighted run and uh you know then you
see that you're like well this is
[__] stupid this is not the way to
live right like the only the only
intelligent response to that is that and
so the trick with DAV goag you want to
be David gagu for one hour a day the
trick with Elon Musk is you only want to
be Elon Musk like 15% of the time in
company right when you're establishing
the vision of like thinking big about
what you're doing he's amazing you want
to channel your inner Elon when you are
um you know telling a story about your
product the way he demos you know Tesla
every time and sells hundreds of
thousands of cars before they're even
ready people pay money just to B pre to
wait for the car right that's when you
want to you want to reserve your thing
or like when he came into Twitter was
like I'm gonna do this really hard thing
hardcore I'm going to do a Sprint I'm
going to sleep in the office and like
I'm going to make sure everybody knows
if you're in this you're in this this in
a hardcore way versus like dude Austin I
don't know how you run your company but
I was always on eggshells with my
employees like like hey we got uh you
know we got to do this tomorrow but if
that's too much Tuesday's okay right
like yeah is that okay with you I don't
I just don't know what the boundaries
are versus like Mr Beast or or David
gogins or Elon these guys have like kind
of no sense of boundaries they just
they're on their mission and you're
either all in or you're out and uh I
think that's pretty cool and that's the
part to steal yeah I think so I think
the the thing to steal in particular is
that Vision right Elon starts with the
vision and then builds a business builds
the business model that's really
impressive I think the way he treats
people the way he some of the things he
says that could that could be in the 85%
of stuff you leave out right right and
actually SBF just kind of the same way
the SP SPF book kind of highlighted a
bunch of things uh that happened my
friend read the SPF book and he was like
I think I'm supposed to hatef uh you
know because of everything that happened
but reading this book made me like a
more and it wasn't because of the spin
he's like actually I found a few things
I really respect about what he did he's
like let's take away the fact that he
was taking cut customer funds to do
these things but like let's just say he
was using the company's money or his own
money or whatever right which he was
also doing he just overextended and Ed
company uh the customer funds too but
they were like the fact that he was like
okay if I have $1 hundred million he
didn't like feel any fear towards losing
it nor did he feel any attachment to it
he's like great let's use the 100
million to pay off Steph Curry you know
Tom Brady and whoever because we're
going to build the brand that way and
like co go and cut absurd deals in order
to pull these things off or like there's
that email that leaked of him and the
guy in LA or the guy he's like I went to
this dinner with this guy in La he's the
most connected person I've ever seen at
this dinner was whoever like you know uh
Nancy Pelosi Leonardo Dicaprio and like
whatever 12 other people he's like we
need to give this guy $200 million to
invest in his fund and I think he'll
open all the doors for us after that
wire him the money out please and like
just the ability to throw your weight
around is actually pretty badass and if
you take away the fraud stuff I I know
other successful people in our life that
do this Andrew Wilkinson does this he
throws his weight around when he wants
something or he like sets his Target on
someone a relationship or a a business
he wants to buy or whatever he really
throws his weight around in a way that I
definitely don't right like Sam what he
wanted to buy the hustle dude he flew me
private up to his House's like oh you
he's like I want to buy this company
let's talk and you're like cool we could
talk on the phone he's like no let's
meet in person you're like I don't like
to fly and Canada's far away he's like
my jet will be there tomorrow let's go
and uh you know he throws his weight
around in a way that I think I am like
often either too cheap or too afraid or
or just don't even think about those
options um and I'm learning to steal
that part of my my game have you guys
thought about that or do you guys think
about how you're gonna use that I'm the
same way as you I appreciate it and I'm
fearful of it it's it's a very scary
thing and but I when I see it I get
inspired yeah I think it's a for me it's
it's a conviction play right I'm more
inspired by uh like I read the the
Warren Buffett book for example right
and he's more cerebral in the way he
does it but it's the same thing it's
like he sees an opportunity and he's not
dipping his toe in the water he's not a
a diversification guy he like oh Bank of
America's going under I'm gonna buy a
ton of preferred debt this is a can't
lose bet and by the way I'm sitting on
however many billions of dollars on my
balance sheet so I'm going to own
whatever 10% of Bank of America and so I
love when people have conviction and
they just say you know what this is it
I'm taking all the chips all the social
capital everything I've made and I'm
doubling down on this dude your chips on
the table moment right now is just
praying Bill Amman doesn't crush your
company because morning Brew Tak your
chips and running away hiding under the
table
actually speaking of throwing your
weight around right that's what he's
doing right now he's trying to throw his
weight around in a way I think I morning
Brew is owned by Business Insider which
is owned by Axel Springer and Bill akman
is at war with bi and axel Springer
Austin I'd like to hear your response to
this yeah what's your official response
you gotta message Bill Hackman to be
like Bill same team same team like I'm
all right yeah I'll save my response for
the private group
chats I think that uh the IDE I think
you don't want to be excited to to just
like plow chips into something because
you're you're you're naturally going to
just kind of make make an impulsive
wrong decision but I do think there's a
good question which is am I throwing my
weight around right like am I um you
know how hard how how much gas versus
how much breakes am I applying to the
things that I want in my life that's one
of my themes I think for this year that
I'm gonna I'm gonna focus on R safy has
this good thing where he talks about
spending and he was like and he'll
messag me privately he's like what
interests you and I'm like well I've got
this cleaning lady that comes every two
weeks I I wish they would come every day
almost and he's like I'm going to
challenge you to figure out what makes
you happy and I want you to spend 10
times the amount that you're spending
now um and so like for him it's like
travel and he goes when I travel I will
spend $50,000 on a trip and that's a ton
of money but that I know that's what
makes me happy and I'm GNA 10 times
spend what I used to spend because
that's what I love and that's what he
was saying to me about um services like
cleaning ladies things like that he goes
I challenge you to spend 10 times more
and that's like a miniature version of
what you're talking about also what
about you you made a bunch of money
selling morning Brew did you use it in
any way that was interesting or like
improve the quality of your life
meaningfully yeah the big thing for me
is I love traveling I love staying at
nice hotels on vacation and so I when I
when I travel that that is my money dial
is traveling I think remitz is two
actually you were texting about this
Aman Hotel what what's the deal do I
need to know about this what what is it
have you heard of it it's just like
supposed to be the fanciest hotel ever
I've heard about it like two times this
year and I don't know if I just started
hanging out with different people or
it's new is this I'm guessing this has
been around for like for like a while
we're growing a lot but essentially Aman
I think is the standard for customer
service for any business right you know
we're talking about the the milk Road
for X I think the a good way to think
about a business is what's the Aman verx
so Aman is just the absolute top
customer service I mean I think the
cheapest Aman there's maybe 60 or 70 of
them the cheapest one is maybe, 1500
bucks a night I think they're regularly
2500 there's one out west somewhere I
think it's I'm on Arizona yeah that's
what people love it's like six grand a
night and people go there and they're
like it was worth it what do they do why
is how would that be worth it well it's
beautiful for one but it's sort of like
remember Sean the bear that episode like
it's touching my body for six grand a
night but you remember like like I
remember the there was like season two
episode six or something is where the
guy goes and learns how to like wash the
silverware perfectly it's like that and
I think that that that type of
Excellence helped make it popular where
people are like oh I respect this
craftsmanship but have you been Austin
I've never been so I've never stayed at
one I'm that's I'm planning my honeymoon
now and that's that's our goal is they
at a bunch of uh amons but I've been to
a bunch when I travel so when I travel I
always try to get like a drink or go to
them they're also interesting because
they're typically not in the heart of a
city they typically are on the outskirts
a little bit they actually and I think
this is really cool I think they do this
intentionally they make you travel there
a little bit right it's not accessible
and that's part of the alur is it's like
a destination you have to really want to
go to an amont to be at the amont now
they've grown and they have one in New
York city so maybe that's not quite as
true but they really want you to to like
be in the Aman Essence when they're
there and it's just again it's it's the
Pinnacle of customer service give me an
example what what are they doing that's
such good customer service yeah like I
went to a motel eight with a slip inside
do they have that I mean the highest
quality food the best quality bed
bedding the mattress every little thing
right when you the toilet paper is
folded the right direction every detail
is perfect and if if
if nice hotels is not your money dial
you're going to be like I just wasted
five grand a night but if if luxury and
having everything you need Tater towards
if that's something that you get joy out
of you're gonna go and you're gonna love
it yeah I get why you like it so no slip
and SL yeah is there a mini fridge
though or
not I just need like Kit Kat and animal
crackers at midnight and I'm gravy like
life's cream cheese just give me that
and and we good uh and a little curig
machine um Austin thanks for coming on
man this is good yeah this F all right
that's the
[Music]
pod